- Some of the people that serve
with me on the House
of Representatives,
even though they may
have noble intentions,
they are useful fools
'cause what they think
that what they're pedaling
is good for others.
No, because they have
never had the experience
of being or living
in Cuba or Venezuela.
Go for two weeks to Havana.
I always tell them
two weeks only,
(Dave laughing)
make it a week with
a Cuban family living
with no dollars and waiting
to come to the United States.
Go live with them for one week
and then you tell me what
the beauties of socialism.
Oh no, because we don't
really want the the Cuban
or the Venezuelan type
of socialism really.
So what socialism
would you like?
- Right.
(upbeat music)
All right, day three of
three in DC continues.
I'm still Dave Rubin.
This is still "The
Rubin Report."
And joining me today
is a congresswoman
representing Florida's
27th District
which happens to be my
district, Maria Salazar.
(both quietly clapping)
Welcome to "The Rubin Report."
- Yes, good, and
welcome to District 27.
- I can't promise you-
- The ultimate melting pot.
- Yeah, it is indeed.
I can't promise you
this is gonna be a very
combative interview
because I told you when you
walked in I voted for you.
Everyone in this
room voted for you.
- Thank you, yes.
Well, you know, you
guys are smart people.
(Dave laughing)
- And we're all pretty thrilled
about what's going
on, obviously.
- And now you live
in my district.
- And I'm in your district.
We're thrilled obviously
with what's going on in
Florida, Miami specifically.
- Yes.
- So before we get into
the nuts and bolts of that,
could you just give the
people that may not know you
a little bit of your history?
You have an interesting work
history and family history
that I think frames a
lot of your politics.
- Sure, of course.
I was first generation
Cuban American.
My parents came to
that city, 1960,
thanks to the United States
that opened up the doors
to 2 million Cubans who were
fleeing probably the most cruel
and the most evil revolution
that the Americas has seen
since the arrival of
Christopher Columbus.
Completely, completely
a bad situation.
So I grew up in Miami.
I have an accent because my
parents could not find work,
like many other
millions of Cubans,
and we had to hop
from island to island.
And I lived in Puerto
Rico some of the time,
another time in Miami.
That's why I speak Spanish.
And I can communicate with 72%
of my district that happens
to be Hispanic descent.
- I may need you to help me
brush up on some Spanish-
- Of course.
- Because yes, everybody
down there is Cuban.
- It's like, hey,
it's all Espanol.
Yes, but we love-
(both speaking in
foreign language)
Yes, but we love the American
exceptionality, and I more,
and that's why I
represent them proudly.
I went to the
University of Miami.
After that I started
working for Univision.
I'm one of the founders
of Spanish television.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Univision and Telemundo.
Then I went to Harvard and
I worked hard at 35 years
in front of the
camera paying my rent.
And after that I decided to
come and serve the country.
And believe me, this is a lot
harder and it pays a lot less.
It is highly gratifying,
highly gratifying to be able
to represent the American values
in the United States Congress.
- So my guys showed
me right before,
your election history
is really interesting
because in 2018 you
lost by three points.
Then in 2020 you
won by three points.
And then in 2022 you won by 13.
- By 15.
- 15?
I had 13 here, but
I'll go with 15.
And that sort of is indicative-
- In two years.
- Of the direction that
Florida's going in, right?
- Well, because the problem is
that the word socialism,
it's highly scary.
And every time a Democratic,
a member of the
Democratic party mentions
democratic socialism,
we run the other way.
Whether you're registered as
Independent or as a Democrat,
it doesn't matter.
30% of Democrat-registered
non-Cuban Hispanics
voted for Salazar 'cause we
do know that they promise
paradise and what you
get is hell at the end.
So anything that has
to do with socialism
or socialist policies, you
may have some social programs
that could benefit
the underprivileged,
but don't give me socialism.
And that's why Maria
Salazar is serving
the most difficult district
in the state of Florida.
Difficult meaning where you are
50/50, it's not that you are
in a very highly concentrated
Republican district.
No, no, no, no.
This is, we're even,
one third Democrats,
one third Republicans,
one third Independent.
- Yeah, and that does
seem to be shifting
though a little bit, right?
Because after this last wave,
I mean, DeSantis
took Miami, which-
- Yes, Miami-Dade County.
- Yeah.
- First time in 20 years
a Republican governor.
Why?
Because we are understanding
that this country,
politically speaking, is not
going the way we need it to.
And what people have to
understand is that people say,
"Well, because Florida
there was a red wave."
Yeah, because you have
people in Florida,
the people who live in Florida
come from either Venezuela
or Cuba or Nicaragua
or Central America.
Right?
- Or worse, Los Angeles.
- Well, okay, alright.
So that, you have a
point of reference.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- You cannot
understand what's black
if you have not seen
white or vice versa.
So once my parents saw
black, really black.
So now when they see white,
they run away because they
have a point of reference.
- [Dave] Yeah.
But unfortunately some of the
members and some of the people
that serve with me on the
House of Representatives,
even though they may
have noble intentions,
they are useful fools
'cause what they think that
what they're pedaling
is good for others.
No, they, because they have
never had the experience
of being or living
in Cuba or Venezuela.
Go for two weeks to Havana.
(Dave laughing)
I always tell them two
weeks only, make it a week
with a Cuban family
living with no dollars
and waiting to come
to the United States.
Go live with them for one week.
And then you tell me what
the beauties of socialism.
Oh no, because we
don't really want
the Cuban or the Venezuelan
type of socialism.
Really, so what
socialism would you like?
- Right.
They want that one
that's never been put
into practice somehow.
- Or that we don't know.
- Yeah.
(Maria laughing)
So how is it for you going
from your district in Miami,
which is highly functional,
I mean, everything,
I'm telling you, like,
I have no complaints.
I wish that you're
my congresswoman.
I wish I could come to you and
be like, fix a couple things.
But it's working.
Our roads are good.
Our police are fantastic.
It's clean, there's
no homeless people.
- No riots.
- There's no drugs on the
streets, there's no riots.
But when you go from
that down in Florida
and then you come here
where it's so dysfunctional
and so crazy, and
just as you said,
you're talking to members of
Congress who have, you know,
their ideas
completely backwards.
How do you put those
two things together?
- You know, it's that we
speak another language.
And I've been trying to,
I've been meaning to sit
with some of the members that
like Democratic socialism
and I've been
wanting to ask them
what is it that you
know that I don't?
I don't know.
Tell me, explain to me,
what is it that you
see that I don't see?
Because Democrats and
Democratic socialists do not
have a monopoly on compassion.
We are compassionate too.
I wanna help those who are,
I wanna help the Browns
and the African Americans
and those kids that
don't have good schooling
because I know that education
is the way out of poverty.
I wanna help them too.
But I don't want to, I
don't want atrophy them
and just give them
money and money, money
and give them the
wrong incentives.
So I don't know what to say.
Maybe it's just I
have it in my DNA.
And like I said,
you know, we lifted.
- Have you been able to
sit down with any of them?
For the record, I've
been telling all of them-
- I have tried.
- We tried to get
AOC here this week.
We tried to get Rashida Tlaib,
we tried to get Ilhan Omar.
I mean, we tried for
everybody and nobody said yes.
- Well, I have specifically
gone to talk to the Black Caucus
because I wanted the
Black Caucus to help me
defend the Afro-Cubans in
Cuba who are being beaten
and brutalized by
the Cuban police.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- When they go on the
streets and scream "Freedom."
That has been my ask, help
me with the Afro-Cubans.
We're not here to talk about
Cuba, the embargo, food.
No, no, no.
We're here to talk about
defending the Afro-Cubans.
They are as Black as you are.
I need you to help
me defend them
because they are
my constituents,
or at least I have constituents
that are their relatives.
But I don't get any response.
- I guess you're
not getting, yeah.
- I do not understand,
because if you come to me
to something that
is so dear to me
as defending African American,
African American rights
and Black Lives
Matters, but, you know,
Black lives matter
across the board.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Not only in the United
States, in Latin America too.
And you have the repressive
apparatus in Havana
repressing those people
who are Afro-Cubans
and who are
screaming and saying,
(speaking in foreign language)
"We want freedom."
So why don't we have
the Black Caucus
in the United
States helping them?
I don't get it.
- Well, I think it would expose
a lot of their hypocrisy-
- And I went to them and I
went to three specific members
and they're saying,
"Yeah, yeah, we
wanna work with you."
Then let's do it.
I'm waiting.
- I'm here, yeah.
(Dave laughing)
I sensed, I sensed.
So things are
working in Florida.
I had Governor DeSantis on a
couple weeks ago and I said,
look, obviously I'm
a supporter of his
and I know how great
things are in Florida.
But I was like, all right, I
gotta ask you one tough one.
So let me ask you
one tough one too.
As you've seen this influx
of people into Florida,
obviously we're having
a house price issue
because they're just
1200 people moving a day.
It's just a function of success.
- [Maria] Yes.
- What can we do about that
beyond just building faster,
which I know they're
trying to do.
Is there anything
else that can be done?
Because a lot of the
original Floridians are now
being priced out and I
don't want them to pay
for doing it right.
- The original
Floridians who said,
that do not have the income or
the right income in order to,
well, I've been talking to
the mayor of the city of Miami
and in my district I'm
trying to find tax incentives
and tax initiatives for
those wealthy developers
to buy land that it's
highly prized at this hour
and be able to
build some workforce
and some affordable housing.
And that's what I'm working on.
There are solutions
and the federal
government can help those
in the private sector
to make some money,
and at the same time,
serve the community.
So that's the way.
- As someone that was part
of the media for
a couple decades.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know, the media tends
not to be too friendly
to some of the ideas
we're talking about here.
- Yeah.
- Does does that surprise
you, or is that just-
- I'm very disappointed
because, I mean,
I'm older now and
I started in 1983.
1983, the American School
of Journalism ruled.
You had the Walter Cronkites,
you had the Peter
Jennings, you had the,
what was the name of that guy
who was doing "Nightline?"
Ted Koppel.
- Yeah.
- You know you did not dare.
- Right, these were
old school journalists.
- Of course.
What do you mean,
giving your opinion?
What?
That was not part of the game.
And right now I'm not sure what
type of journalism we have.
We have commentators,
we have advocates.
And I think that's
confusing the public
when you are watching the
newscast and you think
that what he or she is
saying is facts and news
and it's opinion.
- Even the fact that
every American basically
knows the name AOC and
Ilhan Omar and Rashida Tlaib
and they don't know you, right?
Like at a national level.
And that even sort of
shows it right there.
- Of course, yeah, because
I'm not expressing the-
- You're a scary capitalist.
- Well, that's right.
And a brown girl from the hood.
- Yeah.
- With an accent saying it.
- What do you make of what's
going on in DC right now?
I sense Republicans are kind
of feeling pretty
good about things.
I interviewed Speaker
McCarthy yesterday.
He feels like there's an
agenda to go forward with
that makes sense for people.
Do you feel like there's
really some momentum
and things could change here?
- I think there's momentum
and at least we're
sending the message
and we're telling
the American people
that we are here to try to fix
the national major economic
and social problems.
The border, the
border, major issue.
For 35 years no one has dared
to make that a priority.
And I am, because I
think I can do it.
We gotta seal the border.
We have to seal the border
and put on all the technology
that is out there
available to prevent people
from sneaking in and from
the drugs and the arms,
everything that's illegal coming
and going, seal the border.
And then after you do that,
then review the legal
immigration and review
What are you gonna do
with the 13 million people
who are right now here watching
us that do not have papers?
What are you gonna do with them?
- I take it you
were pretty thrilled
when these illegals come
through Texas or whatever,
they make it to Florida,
and then Governor DeSantis
basically puts them on a bus
and sends them to Delaware
or to Martha's Vineyard, or-
- Or DC.
It's just, yeah, but that's
not that's not the way
we fix the problem.
- Right.
- I'm trying to fix their
problem at the root.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Don't let them
come in illegally.
And if they are then you
know what they're gonna,
why are they here?
Give them a legal visa.
You know, we can talk
about my dignity program
whenever you want to, but we
do have to fix the problem.
How are we gonna fix it?
You know, there has to be,
otherwise you, I mean,
you keep on having...
What's happening,
it's unthinkable.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- They're coming in and they
don't have work permits.
So how do you think
that they're gonna live?
How are they gonna eat?
- We're gonna give
them a bunch of stuff.
- Well, that's not the
way to do it either.
(Dave laughing)
- Right.
- What do you mean, giving
them government programs?
No!
- I'm not for it.
I'm just telling you, what the
Democrats are gonna do, yeah.
- No, you work.
I'll let you in, but
you have to work.
And how are you gonna work?
I have to give you
a piece of paper
that gives you a permit,
but at the same time,
I'm letting you in
if you are not legal.
So that's why I'm saying
stop this madness.
- Are there any democrats,
like when you hear Mayorkas
basically being like, "Oh
the border's not open,"
and yet we have more
border crossings than ever,
than ever in this past year.
It's just outright lies.
- Whatever, what the
politicians are saying.
You know, what's the
empirical evidence?
The empirical evidence is
that we need to
solve this problem.
And like I said, I'm the
only Republican member
of Congress that has put
together an initiative
called The Dignity Act
and we can review it
whenever you want to.
And it solves the
problem because let
me tell you something,
we also have a legal
immigration problem.
What does that mean?
That if you want to attract
the Albert Einsteins
of the world, if you
wanna bring the best minds
leaving Ukraine or
Russia or China,
you need to give them a
visa for them to come in.
And that legal
path is not so easy
to come into the United States.
You know that too, right?
- [Dave] Yeah.
- That's not good
for our economy.
- Yeah.
So Miami though has an
incredible economy right now
and we're growing, and
obviously Mayor Suarez
has done an unbelievable
job bringing,
I mean we're basically the
tech leader now in the world.
- [Maria] Yes.
- How has that changed
the way you've thought
about your constituents
and, you know,
all of these new people
fitting into all of this?
- Well, I think that the
system takes care of itself.
And you see, right now you just
said at the housing market,
now we have more shops.
My constituents are doing
better, economically speaking,
because we have people like
you coming in and consuming.
The market always finds its way.
But the only thing
I can tell you is
that if you love the system
like we do, and District 27,
some of my people, the
people that are serving you
and your staff may not
know English that well
but the English
is in their heart.
- Yeah, I'm working on it.
I mean, everyone that
comes in my house,
they're teaching me Spanish.
I'm teaching them English.
That's the...
- I welcome you to ask them
what do you think about
the United States?
Oh, America, we love America.
Yes, yes, yes, best country.
You just, just, you know.
- No, trust me, I know it.
I'm out there with my
landscapers every week
and we're talking-
- Best country on earth,
best country, this country,
my country, just got here
two years ago or something.
- Yeah, but they also, one of
the things that I've found,
and this is definitely different
than some of the immigrants
in LA, and I don't think this,
it tends to be more Mexican
there, where it's more-
- [Maria] Of course.
- Cuban and Venezuelan here.
- [Maria] Yes.
- The work ethic
is unbelievable.
These guys are busting
their butts constantly.
- Because we don't want
anyone to give us anything.
Because if you make
it for yourself,
which is what I
was trying to say
to the underprivileged
communities,
I don't want the
Democratic socialists
to be teaching our children
that, let me give you,
no, no, let me give
you the opportunity
for you to earn it
yourself and not take away
from you that joy and
the taste that I made it
and that I am a
successful human being.
Because look, whether it's
a landscaping company,
whether it's a car dealership
or like me, you know,
I made it to Congress.
Wow, in one generation.
(Dave laughing)
- Pretty good.
- And how do you
think I did that?
Because the system gave
me the opportunity.
I busted my butt
working on television.
Oh Jesus, did I, but
that gave me the platform
for people to, I mean,
'cause I have the platform
because Univision, private
sector, they paid very well.
I was on the air, I was on
the air every day, you know,
Monday through
Friday, eight o'clock,
whether I wanted to or not.
(Dave laughing)
I went to work, I went to work.
I had the opportunity, I
grabbed the opportunity.
And then after that
I ran for Congress.
What?
Where else do you think
you could do that?
Here.
Nowhere else, in
Cuba, Venezuela,
Nicaragua, Panama, Dominican,
in, Argentina, in Chile,
in Uruguay, Paraguay, no,
only the United States.
So how are you gonna come
and tell me that this
is a bad country?
Really?
Tell me where.
(Maria laughing)
- This might be the easiest
interview I've ever done
in my life because
I mean, the passion-
- But it's true, think about it.
- The passion and the reality.
- Of course.
- And I have nothing
to complain about-
- Don't touch the Constitution,
don't touch the United States.
It may not perfect, of
course it's not perfect.
The system needs to be fixed.
Of course.
I know that there
are some grievances,
that we have to redress
some of the minorities,
some of the African Americans
have not had the opportunity
that they deserve when
it comes to schooling,
when it comes to housing.
I get it.
Fix it and move on and
have a better society.
Not like, ah,
let's destroy this.
No, what do you mean destroy?
That's what Fidel said.
"Let's destroy this because
this system is really bad."
Look what they got.
(Maria laughing)
That's what Maduro said.
- I got nothing else for you.
I guess all I can
leave us with is about-
- But it's empirical evidence.
Maduro, let me just
tell you real quick.
- Yeah.
(Dave laughing)
- Venezuela, Venezuela,
perfect example.
I interviewed Chavez in 2020.
2020 was five minutes ago
when it comes to the
grand scheme of things
2020 Chavez said to me,
"Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going to implement
Democratic socialism."
I'm like "What, really?"
"Yeah, let's confiscate,
confiscate, confiscate."
Venezuela has the largest
reserves of oil in the world,
was the largest and
the most important,
the most robust economy
in Latin America.
Largest reserves
of oil, you know,
so then you have a lot to sell.
They have wood, they have
minerals, they have water,
they have land,
they have people.
Right now the average
Venezuelan wastes
20 pounds less because of
lack of food in Venezuela
- Yeah, I've seen those videos.
- Seven million, seven
million Venezuelans have fled.
What?
Because Chavez wanted to
implement Democratic socialism.
And he said the same thing.
"I'm not gonna do it
like Fidel did it.
No, no, no.
I'm gonna do it the right way."
And look.
- There ain't no right way.
All right, I got two
things for you, number one-
- Sorry, sorry that
I, you know, but.
- Number one, I wanna
host you at the house.
We'll get some of
my Florida friends
and we'll talk about
how great Florida is
and what's your favorite
restaurant in Coral Gables?
How about Lulu?
Have you been to Lulu in-
- Of course.
- I love Lulu, that
Italian, oh, it's good.
- Well, I wanna tell
you a secret one.
- Yeah, you got one for me?
- Yes.
Right there, you have a Brachi?
- I haven't been there.
- Oh, it's an institution.
And you have another one
that has been founded
by a Colombian who
fled and his name,
and it's liquor something.
And it's right there.
And it's a beautiful tapas.
You eat some tapas and you
would drink some good wine.
So I will treat you to that one.
And then you treat me
to an American one.
- Normally I don't end
an interview like this,
but we're gonna high five.
All right.
- Thank you, and thank
you for the opportunity.
- It was my pleasure.
- And let's hope the
average American understands
what I'm saying.
Let's preserve the system.
(calm music)
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead
of mindless dribble, check
out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.